the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we're going to learn a rather
powerful technique called the technique
of partial fractions that's particularly
applicable for one special type of
integrand in particular it's going to be
applicable through the situation where
the integral has the form the quotient
of two polynomials in other words
suppose we have integral P of xdx over Q
of X where P and Q are both polynomials
in X and by the way for reasons that
will become apparent later we'll assume
that the degree of P is less than the
degree of Q in other words that the
highest exponent in the numerator is
less than the highest exponent in the
denominator by the way if that's not the
case we can always carry out long
division first and carry out enough
terms until we get a term in which this
is the particular case you see I'll make
that clearer as we go along but for the
time being all we really care about in
terms of outlining this form and again
as we will often do in these types of
techniques the place that will pick up
the real fine computational points are
in the exercises we've used the lectures
to just sort of outline what the
technique is and how it's used but
suppose now that we have the quotient of
two polynomials and we want to integrate
it now the idea is this there are two
key steps that dictate this particular
method the first thing is that we saw in
the last lecture that we can handle
denominators if they involve nothing
worse than linear and quadratic
polynomials in other we know how to
integrate something like DX over X plus
a constant we know now how to integrate
DX over ax squared plus BX plus C so we
know how to handle that type okay and
the second important thing and I'll
amplify this too as we go along the
second important thing is that
theoretically every real polynomial can
be factored into linear and quadratic
terms now this is a little bit
misleading if we try to read more into
this than when it really says it doesn't
mean that we can always fine
a factorization quite simply in other
words we may at best be able to
approximate a route we won't have to use
things like we've talked about in the
notes so far Newton's method and things
like this linear approximations
tangential approximations we may have to
approximate the roots but that
theoretically if a polynomial with real
coefficients has degree greater than two
it has at least one real root in other
words we can keep factoring things out
this way the only thing we can't do is
to guarantee that once we get down to a
quadratic that we can get real roots out
of this particular thing in fact the
classic example is to visualize x
squared plus 1 in other words we can't
factor x squared plus 1 unless we
introduce non real numbers remember the
technique you can write that x squared
plus 1 is x squared minus I squared
where I is the square root of minus 1
and this factors into X plus I times X
minus I etcetera but these are non real
numbers in other words you can't always
factor a quadratic to get real numbers
in fact if you recall the quadratic
formula of this beast square root of b
squared minus 4ac if B squared is less
than 4ac what's inside the square root
sign is negative and that leads to non
real roots so you see we can't always
factor quadratics into real factors by
the way don't identify things that were
difficult to factor with things that
can't be factored you know a lot a lot
of times we think of say here's an
example I thought you might enjoy seeing
here take for example X to the fourth
plus one that looks something like it
belongs to the family x squared plus one
and x squared plus one can't be factored
you might think that X to the fourth
plus one can't be factored now again
it's not important that you understand
what made me think of these tricks or
what have you what I do want to show is
that even situations where the
polynomials might look like they don't
factor they really do for example when X
to the fourth plus one we can write this
in the disguised form x squared plus one
squared so that's what X to the fourth
plus one but as the middle term here of
two x squared so I subtract off
two x-squared now this has the form the
sum and difference of two squares namely
x squared plus one squared and also the
square root of two times x squared in
other words I can write this as this
plus the square root of two times x
times this minus the square root of two
times x observing that even though the
square root of two is an irrational
number it is nonetheless a real number
the important point that I want to point
out though as far as setting up this
technique called partial fractions is
that whether it's easy or not easy the
fact remains that when we have a
polynomial in our denominator it can
always be factored into a combination of
linear and quadratic factors okay using
real numbers
well it's difficult to factor some of
these things so by way of illustration
let me pick out one that comes factored
let me start with a particular problem
here let's take the integral DX over X
minus 1 times x squared plus 1 C what is
the integrand in this case it's 1 over X
minus 1 times x squared plus 1 now the
idea is this here's a quadratic factor
here's a linear factor what fractions do
I have to add to wind up with something
like this well again and this is gonna
be another example of our old adage
that's easier to scramble an egg than to
unscramble one you see given two
fractions it's one thing to find their
sum given the sum it's quite another
thing computationally to find what
fractions you have to add to get that
sum the idea is this if you wind up with
a denominator that has an X minus 1 term
an x squared plus 1 term it appears that
you must have styled with terms say what
in other words you must have had one
term which has a nominator of X minus 1
and a term which had a denominator of x
squared plus 1 because you see if I
start with these kind of denominators
when I cross multiply and put things
over a common denominator I will wind up
with X minus 1 times x squared plus 1
the question that comes up is what shall
our numerators bill
and here's the main reason why we picked
the degree of the numerator to be less
than the degree of the denominator
notice for example in this particular
case this is a the numerator has degree
0 namely the highest power of X that
appears is the X to the 0 term on the
other hand the denominator has degree 3
see there's an X cubed term in the
denominator you see if there had been an
X to the 4th in the numerator I could
have multiplied out the denominator
divided into the numerator and just kept
carrying out the division long enough
until I wound up with a remainder which
was less than a degree less than a cubic
in other words less than the
third-degree polynomial remainder that's
not the point the point is that as long
as the degree of the numerator is less
than the degree of the denominator it
means that the terms that we're adding
must have the degree of the numerator
less than the degree of the denominator
see it's sort of like adding fractions
if you start with one fraction whose
numerator is greater than the
denominator then certainly any sum that
you get is going to be bigger than one
though is if you want to start wind up
with dealing with positive numbers and
you want to wind up with a fraction
which is less than 1 it stands to reason
that all the fractions that you're
adding must be less than one so if I'm
going to wind up adding quotients of
polynomials to get a say sum in which
the degree of the numerator is less than
the degree of the denominator it means
that every one of the terms in my sum
must have this particular property in
other words with this as a hint I say
look at my denominator here is X minus 1
that's degree 1 that means my numerator
can't be greater than degree 0 but
degree zero means a constant so I say ok
that means that this has the form some
constant over X minus 1 now I look at
this denominator it's quadratic and I
say to myself I'm starting out with a
quadratic the degree of the numerator
can't be greater than a degree of the
denominator since the degree of the
denominator is 2 that means the degree
of the numerator can't mean can't be
more than 1 and the most general
first-degree polynomial has the form 1
some constant times X plus
a constant so what I'm saying is okay to
wind up with something of the form what
wind up with one over X minus one times
x squared plus one I had better start
with something of the form a over X
minus one plus BX plus C over x squared
plus one where a B and C are constants
the key point is that if we weren't sure
that the degree of the numerator were
less than the degree of the denominator
we would not know where to stop in our
numerator in other words by this
convention we're sure that the degree of
the numerator in any one of these terms
can't be greater than a degree of the
corresponding denominator you see and by
the way notice for example if it turns
out that we put too much in for example
suppose it turns out that this numerator
here should only be a constant there's
no law against having B turn out to be
zero by the way again what these things
are called just to increase our
vocabulary this is called what I'm going
to do now is called the method of
undetermined coefficients you see what I
know is is that I must have the form a
over X minus one plus BX plus C over x
squared plus one well I don't know is
specifically how to choose the values of
a B and C and the technique works
something like this what we do is is we
put this over a common denominator
what will the common denominator be
it'll be X minus one times x squared
plus one how will I put this over a
common denominator it'll be a times x
squared plus one plus BX plus C times X
minus one now this is supposed to be an
identity
now if two fractions are identical and
the denominators are the same which is
what they will be after I put this over
a common denominator the only way they
can be identical is for the numerators
to be identical so you see what I'm
going to do is to cross multiply here to
obtain the numerator of the right hand
side and then I will equate that to the
numerator on the left hand side which is
1 alright now what is the numerator on
the right hand side it's a times x
squared plus 1
that's a x squared plus a then it's
going to be X minus 1 times BX plus C
that's going to be
be x squared minus BX plus C times X
minus C and now the idea is something
like this and I'll come back to this in
a few moments to hammer this home from a
different point of view what is the
coefficient of x squared on the
right-hand side of the equation the
coefficient of x squared on the right
hand side of the equation is a plus B
what is the coefficient of x squared on
the left hand side of the equation and
at first glance you say there is no x
squared on the left hand side of the
equation what that means of course is
that the coefficient of x squared on the
left hand side of the equation is zero
so we say is okay the coefficients of x
squared must match up there for a plus B
which is the coefficient of x squared on
the right hand side must equal zero
which is the coefficient of x squared on
the left hand side in a similar way the
coefficient of x is C minus B on the
right hand side the coefficient of x on
the left hand side is zero consequently
C minus B must be zero and finally the
constant term on the right hand side is
given by a minus C on the left hand side
the right hand term is one consequently
a minus C must equal one what do I wind
up with three three equations with three
unknowns well there are a number of ways
of handling these things the easiest one
I see offhand is I noticed if I add the
first two equations I wind up with a
plus C is 0 normally a plus C is 0 and
also that a minus C is 1 it's easy for
me to conclude that a must be 1/2 and C
must be minus 1/2 and by the way now
knowing what a and C are I can use
either of these two equations to
determine B and B turns out to be minus
1/2 in other words what does this tell
me it tells me that if I replace a here
by 1/2 and B and C each by minus 1/2 the
right hand side here will be an identity
for the left hand side there'll be two
different ways of naming the same number
for each value of x in fact doing this
now out in more
detail what we've really shown here in
other words if I replace a by a half and
B and C each by minus 1/2 then I factor
the 1/2 out what I've shown is that 1
over the quantity X minus 1 times x
squared plus 1 is equal to 1/2 times the
quantity 1 over X minus 1 minus the
quantity X plus 1 over x squared plus 1
by the way I can separate this into two
terms each of which has a denominator of
x squared plus 1 and I get what 1/2
times 1 over X minus 1 minus 1/2 times X
over x squared plus 1 minus 1/2 times 1
over x squared plus 1 now the key is
this I didn't really want this what I
wanted was what this was to be my
integrand
what I wanted was was to integrate this
with respect to X well if given this
identity over here the integral of DX
over X minus 1 times x squared plus 1
recalling that the integral of a sum is
the sum of the integrals etc can now be
written as what it's 1/2 integral DX
over X minus 1 minus 1/2 integral X over
x squared plus 1 times DX minus 1/2
integral 1 over x squared plus 1 times
DX now here's the point notice that
every one of my denominators now is
either linear or quadratic in fact
without going through the details here
again if I let u equal X minus 1 in this
example this reduces this to the form D
u over u in other words are you to the
end do you form if I let u equal x
squared plus 1 over here my if u is x
squared plus 1 notice that D U is 2x DX
so my numerator becomes a constant
multiple of D U and again I have the U
the ndu form and finally if I look at my
last integral here notice that this is
the sum of two squares which suggests
the circular trigonometric functions
that were
about last time or if you wish you can
go to tables and look these things up
they're all in there but again without
going through the details because this
is the easy part again it turns out that
once you have this relationship here we
can integrate this to obtain log
absolute value X minus 1 the integral
here is log natural log absolute value
of x squared plus 1
I can leave the absolute value signs out
because x squared plus 1 has to be at
least as big as 1 it can't be negative
and finally either by trigonometric
substitution or by memorization or
what-have-you
integral DX over x squared plus 1 is
just the inverse tangent of X in other
words by using partial fractions and
reducing a complicated polynomial
denominator into a sum of linear and
quadratic terms I was able by knowing my
techniques of last time to integrate the
given expression and by the way I would
be a little remiss at the stage of the
game if I did not take the time to once
again reinforce a very important concept
and that is it may be difficult starting
with this to get this what should not be
difficult is starting with this to be
able to differentiate it and show that
you wind up with 1 over X minus 1 times
x squared plus 1 in other words as usual
with the inverse derivative once you
find an answer and you want to see
whether your answer is correct or not
all you have to do is differentiate the
answer and see if you get the integrand
but at any rate this is how the
technique called
partial fractions works it works for the
quotient of two polynomials and to make
the undetermined coefficients technique
work right
you must assume that the degree of the
numerator is less than the degree of the
denominator and obviously in the
exercises I'll give you some where the
degree of the numerator is greater than
the degree of the denominator and if you
don't perform long division first you're
going to get into trouble trying to find
the answer to the problem but all I want
to emphasize here is the technique and
by the way what I want to do before I go
any further also is to emphasize a
rather special property of polynomial I
don't
this he recall that undetermined
coefficients hinged on the following and
I'll pick a quadratic the illustrated
with suppose you have two quadratic
expressions in X identically equal in
other words a sub 2x squared plus a sub
1 X plus a sub 0 was identically equal
to B sub 2 x squared plus B sub 1 X plus
B 0 notice the technique that we use was
as we said look at let's compare the
coefficients of x squared let's equate
the coefficients of X and let's equate
the constant terms how do we know that
you're allowed to do this well let's see
if we can show that this must be the
case for example let's do this what any
calculus at all suppose this is an
identity if this is an identity it must
be true for all values of X in
particular it must be true when X is 0
notice that when X is 0 the left hand
side is a sub 0 the right hand side is B
sub 0 and we wind up with a sub 0 equals
B sub 0 see the constant terms were
equal well if a sub 0 equals B sub 0 we
can cancel a sub 0 and B sub 0 from this
equation that leaves us with this
equaling this from this we can factor
out an X and get that x times a sub 2 X
plus a 1 is identical with x times B sub
2 X plus B 1 if X is not 0 we can cancel
X from both sides of the equation and
that shows what that for any nonzero
value of x a 2 X plus a 1 must be
identically equal to B 2 X plus B 1 once
we have this formula established let's
let X equal 0 and here and we see what
would actually equal to 0 that a 1
equals B 1 in other words that the
coefficient of x on the left hand side
equals the coefficient of x on the right
hand side you can keep on this way but a
very nice technique to use here is a
reinforcement of something that we
talked about before I think it was when
we're doing implicit differentiation and
we talked about identities versus
equations you see if this is an identity
and what I mean by an identity that this
we're not saying
what values of X this is true for buy an
identity we're saying look at these two
expressions are the same for all values
of x they're synonyms and what we're
saying is if these two things are
synonyms their derivatives must be
synonyms and all we're saying is look at
if you want to use calculus here
differentiate both sides of this
expression and you wind up with two a
sub 2x plus a 1 is identically equal to
2 P sub 2 X plus B 1 since these two
things are identical let's equate their
derivatives again see the derivative of
identities are identical and we wind up
with 2 a 2 is identically equal to 2 B 2
and therefore a 2 must equal B 2 knowing
that a 2 equals B 2 we can come back to
this step and show that a 1 equals B 1
and now knowing that a 2 equals B 2 and
a 1 equals B 1 we can come back to the
original equation and show that a 0 must
equal B 0 now you may wonder why are we
making all of this a do-over such what
appears to be a very obvious thing and I
would like to give you a caution here
I'd like you to beware of something it's
something which works very nicely for
polynomials but doesn't always have to
work all the time in fact later when one
studies differential equations this
becomes a very important concept which
later gets the name linear dependence
and linear independence we're not going
to go into that now but the key idea is
this in general knowing that a1 nu 1
plus a 2 u 2 is equal to b1 nu 1 plus B
2 u 2 you cannot say ah therefore the
coefficients of U 1 must be equal and
the coefficients of U 2 must be equal
don't get me wrong if a1 equals b1 and
a2 equals b2 then certainly a 1 u 1 plus
a 2 u 2 is equal to B 1 u 1 plus B 2 u 2
I'm not saying that what I'm saying is
conversely if you start knowing that
this is true it does not follow that
they must match up coefficient by
coefficient okay and you say well why
doesn't have to follow and I think the
best way to do that is by means of is
ample for example in this general
expression let u 1 equal X and let u to
be x over 2
look at the expression 5x plus 6 times x
over 2 that's what it's 5x plus 3 X is
8x look at 3 X plus 10 times X over 2
that's 3x plus 5x which is also 8 X in
other words 5 times X plus 6 times X
over 2 is identically equal to 3 times X
plus 10 times X over 2 yet you can't say
therefore the coefficients of x must be
equal and the coefficients of x over 2
must be equal in fact if you said that
you'd be saying that 5 is equal to 3 and
6 is equal to 10 which of course is not
true ok
so at any rate I just wanted to show you
here
the kind of mathematical rigor and
cautions that have to be taken if one is
going to use the technique called
partial fractions what what the key
ingredients are now it turns out that
not only a partial fraction is important
in their own right it also turns out
that partial fractions handles a rather
difficult type of integral one that uses
polynomials in sine X and cosine X and
the reason I wanted to mention this was
not so much because the technique is
nice the technique by the way is in the
text but there's something very
interesting in the text the way the
author introduces the topic and I
thought that that was worth an aside in
its own right
in the section where this thing appears
it says it has been discovered that the
author makes no attempt to show
logically why one would expect that a
certain thing is going to work all the
author says is it has been discovered
that and this tells a long story that in
many cases we wind up with an integrand
that we don't know how to handle we make
all sorts of substitutions in the hope
that we can reduce the given integral to
a form that we know how to handle
sometimes we're successful sometimes
we're not in the cases where were not
successful somebody either by clever
intuition or what-have-you
maybe just blind luck stumbles across
the technique that happens to work and I
sort of liked this particular example in
the text where the author says it has
been discovered that because to me it's
not a lot of self-evident and yet it's a
rather pretty result the result says
this suppose you make the substitution Z
equals tangent x over 2 now where do you
pull this out of the Hat from Z equals
tangent x over 2 that's the ingenuity
the experience the luck but the idea is
let's suppose that we stumbled across
this one way or the other if we
translate this equation into a reference
triangle we have what that will call the
angle x over 2 and the tangent is Z so
we'll make the side opposite Z the side
adjacent one that makes the hypotenuse
the square root of 1 plus Z squared now
watch what happens when you do this see
Z is equal to 10 x over 2 therefore DZ
is the differential of ten x over to
remember the differential of tan X with
respect to X is secant squared but we
also by the chain rule have to multiply
by a derivative of x over two with
respect to X in other words if Z is ten
x over 2 DZ is not secant squared X over
two it's 1/2 secant squared X over 2 DX
but what secant squared X over 2
let's go back and look at our diagram
the secant of X over two is the
hypotenuse over site adjacent that's the
square root of one plus Z squared over
one and therefore the square of the
secant is just one plus Z squared over
one C one plus Z squared so with the 1/2
in here this becomes one plus Z squared
over two x DX and consequently if I
compare these two now notice that DX is
just twice DZ over one plus Z squared in
other words what's happened to DX it's
been replaced by a differential in Z
which involves the quotient of two
polynomials so DX comes out very nicely
this way in terms of what the quotient
of two polynomials
how about sine X and cosine X and again
notice the dependency on identities sine
X is twice sine x over two cosine X over
two but from my reference triangle I can
pick off the trigonometric functions of
x over two very easily namely the sine
of X over two is just Z over the square
root of one plus Z squared and the
cosine of X over 2 is just 1 over the
square root of one plus Z squared
plugging that in here I find that sine X
is twice Z over the square root of 1
plus Z squared times 1 over the square
root of 1 plus Z squared multiplying
this out I find what that sine X is
twice Z and the square root of 1 plus Z
squared times itself is just 1 plus Z
squared in other words sine X is 2 Z
over 1 plus Z squared in other words
with the substitution what happens to
sine X it becomes 2 Z over 1 plus Z
squared which is also the quotient of
two polynomials in Z ok finally how
about cosine X what identity can we use
to reduce cosine X in terms of x over 2
why do we want the x over 2 again notice
that even though we may not have
invented this substitution by ourselves
once it's invented the relationship to
the angle x over
- becomes very apparent at any rate
notice the identity that says that
cosine 2x is cosine squared X minus sine
squared X translates into cosine X is
cosine squared of half the angle minus
sine squared of half the angle well
cosine squared X over two well cosine X
over 2 is just 1 over the square root of
1 plus Z squared so cosine squared X
over 2 is just 1 over 1 plus Z squared
similarly sine squared X over 2 is just
Z squared over 1 plus Z squared and what
we find is that cosine X is 1 minus Z
squared over 1 plus Z squared and again
what's happened cosine X is now
expressible as the quotient of two
polynomials in Z in fact as an
application of this let's come back to
an integrand that's been giving us some
trouble for quite some time now let's
look at the integral secant X DX and see
if we can't use this technique that
we've just learned to solve this
particular problem
notice that secant is 1 over cosine
therefore integral secant X DX is
integral DX over cosine X now let's come
back here for a moment just to refresh
our memories we saw that DX was 2 DZ
over 1 plus Z squared we saw that cosine
X was 1 minus Z squared over 1 plus Z
squared therefore 1 over cosine X will
just be the reciprocal of this in other
words coming back here now we can
replace DX by 2 DZ over 1 plus Z squared
and 1 over cosine X by 1 plus Z squared
over 1 minus Z squared ok therefore in
terms of this substitution integral
secant X DX is just twice integral DZ
over 1 minus Z squared but what is this
integrand this integrand is the quotient
of two polynomials in Z therefore I
could use partial fractions here write
this as a
something over 1 plus Z plus something
over 1 minus Z etc solve the problem in
terms of Z and then remembering that Z
is tangent x over 2 I can then replace Z
by what it's equal to in terms of X and
in that way solve the problem now you
see what I want you to see again that
comes through here all the time is how
we are continually looking for ways of
reducing integrals to equivalent
integrals but hopefully ones that are
more familiar to us meaning what
ones that we are able to handle in the
next lesson we're going to find a very
powerful technique which is far more
general than partial fractions a
technique which is used over and over
again which is probably the single most
important technique but I won't say any
more about that right now
we'll continue with this discussion next
time and until next time goodbye funding
for the publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and Paul
Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate